One of the first things I
remember just making so much
of a stunning impression
on me as a kid was Cher.
You don't know me.
I just did not understand
who or what she was
other than magnificent.
Growing up, watching
Cher and her trajectory,
beautiful and magnificent as she was on
The Sonny and Cher Show,
and then when
she went on
to do her
own show.
She just had these clothes,
which later I learned, they
were Bob Mackie designs,
and just blew me away.
And she continues to blow us away.
I used to really love snowboarding.
So they told me, "Why don't
you try snowboarding?"
I was a little gun shy, but
I said, "Let me try it."
I got it. I was out there.
You know, I'm from LA, you can skateboard.
Went back the next time,
maybe two or three
years later, still good.
Maybe about seven years
ago, went back out there,
took a spill.
Oh, I feel the pain
right now in this moment.
One thing I could tell you guys
I will never ever do again,
even with a check involved, is snowboard.
I just love great storytelling.
If it's a great story, I'm
still gonna show up for it.
There are some films
that I have watched over
and over and over again
and still to this day.
The Godfather, part one.
I know that that's, you know,
an argument for a lot of people,
part one versus two.
Part one. Just no, it's
not an argument, no.
Part one.
The Godfather.
And Coming to America,
still watch it over and over to this day.
Damn right.
That's the beauty of storytelling.
Sally Field
inspired me to want to become an actress.
At a young age, what
she did
with Norma Rae
and what she did with
Sybil was just mindblowing
that that was the same human being.
I was so young with Norma Rae
that I really didn't
understand it probably fully
until I got a little older
and got to see it again.
And then–
Still to this day.
I want to make people feel
the way she makes me feel
or the way I felt when I saw those films.
I take the moment in, just
like when I was a kid, now.
Just seeing that brings me joy.
It's joy in everything.
Check out
The Harder They Fall,
only on Netflix.